hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight show of class chess
international my name is satyagraha Mian
and I'm going to take you to the key
moments of day six which was also final
day of the semi-finals
first of all congratulations to Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiano Khurana for
advancing to the finals
of course it comes as no surprise that
the numbers one and two players will be
meeting in the finals but it was
actually acquired to journey so for
Magnus Carlsen it was a smooth sailing
as he entered the day with a four-point
advantage he he had a excellent day on
day 1 where his Fabiano Khurana was four
points behind Wesley saw so there was a
hurdle here to overcome which he did
here heroic Lee so let's jump to the
games and let's see how they too went
down so let's start with our match
between West's own Fabiana Khurana so
this was an extremely exciting match so
much went down and this is not the
comeback that was easy to do because
four points is a lot and Fabiano in the
postgame interview said that it for him
it didn't matter if he was going to lose
by one points or eight points so he came
with a fighting spirit we see that black
team is doing well like his upper pond
so he finds his crucial move of Queen a1
going into this Queen endgame which he
thought is winning so let's check out
his technique so objectively this
position is winning for pot but let's
take a look how the world number 2
player actually wins it so the King
starts to run and as we can see the main
advantage for black are of course these
two passed pawns so coin makes room full
of pawns and this was the cheque that
really didn't help
Wesley because the King just starts
running towards the pawns
the queen is really well placed here
defending this guy
and pushing the punt so a black is going
to be the first one to Quinn because he
is stopping this pond and also eyeing
this pond with a check so if this Quinn
moves and we will take only six with a
check so the Queen moves closer and the
Queen is actually very funny so close to
the king but there are no checks so he
gives up the Queen for a couple of
checks but the King is going to hide
behind the pawns so very convenient as
there's no Queen d5 check and here was
the result so now the score is still in
favor of Wesley so but now the advantage
shrinks to three points so let's move to
Game two and move 38 so Fabiano Curran
and now with the white pieces it plays
Queen Devon and very logically was the
decides to take but actually he should
have hung on to the knight so this is
the move that engine offers which is I
think it's difficult to play because the
night you know you're weakening your
king your knight kind of maybe looks
like it's getting stranded but
objectively this is the best move in the
position so let's see what happened
after after it takes you five
twenty-four and we do know that night
and a queen are a great combination when
it comes to attacking so they're they
pair really well so takes the pawn which
is also very logical so we're going to
see another Queen endgame and this
Knight is actually excellently placed so
this King gets much safer and this b5
pawn it's going to fall and this guy is
going to become very dangerous when it
comes back it's not stopping any kind of
g3 tricks and starts pushing the pawn
keeps pushing the pump and as we
mentioned white kink is safer and this
king is not an amazing piece so actually
after Queens III Wesley simply resigned
because it's actually hard to suggest a
good move for him for example if the
bishop moves then white will check and
white can try several things one of them
being 97 even giving up this pawn and
going after this fun and actually just
starting an attack against this King so
very difficult position and Wesley
resigned so let's jump to our third game
so of course after this two wins now the
gap has narrowed even more another
difference is two points so if Wesley
keeps losing if he loses two more games
now the match will be even going into
the clutch games and then it's
everyone's game so he takes Bishop c7
and looks like white is winning a pawn
in a really clever way and Fabiano here
tonight before but he had this amazing
move Queen h2 because you know you're
looking to lose your Queen anyway so I'm
like it might as well get something for
it
so not the most difficult tactic in the
world but you know you have to keep an
eye out or be aware that it's in the
position and the game could have ended
into them in a more peaceful manner in
this position because the rook will come
to c8
like will successfully fight for the C
file again it's a long game anything can
happen in a long game but the Atlas
black is doing okay and not to mention
this guy's hanging so let's go to the
game so instead he takes the Queen and
Hunter who comes to the semi rank so
they're still of course a lot of fight
in this game I'm just going to move to
pieces and take you to the other key
moment that caused Fabiano the game so
white is doing well white has an extra
pawn puck does have the bishop and we're
going to see that the King gets quite
active so not easy to win and it means I
actually really like how Fabiano is
playing if you take a look at what's
going on
the queenside and in a few moves we're
going to see how this rook gets locked
in so a lot of exchange is happening the
bishop goes to d3 and Trust the rook so
very resourceful play by Fabiano
Colorado and surprisingly so we repeat
the position a few times so reaching our
we're nearing our key moment so Knight
c3 forcing the matter is attacking the
bishop on the pawn so forcing to go down
to this exchange and once again we have
a rock endgame as we're seeing this a
lot of many times already in this match
if you've been following either watching
my other recaps and working on games are
just never easy as yessir said that he's
never he can't think of a single strong
player who has an last root end game
while on the better side of it so
basically he doesn't know can't think of
a strong player who has a messed up
Oregon game a winning routine game so
they're very difficult so here
Fabiana makes an error by playing rook a
to so he chooses the wrong plan and we
will see in the game white Wesley
basically demonstrated why this was a
mistake by his very good play
so instead Fabiana should have tried
something like rugby 3 so it's a temple
move and if the rook moves then the King
comes here assisting this pawn and we're
going to get one of those end games you
know when you're pushing your pawn and
your opponent is pushing theirs so this
roof might have to eventually sacrifice
itself and the game should it would best
play the game should end in a draw but
again we are talking about very
difficult end games and they are nearing
the end of the game so they don't have a
lot of time on their clock so we expect
errors so Rho K 2 was played and let's
see how Wesley so punished his opponent
so f 4 was played
rook o sweet o attacking the pawn end
well so just ignores this and takes
these funds and now we see how White's
pawns are just so much faster
it just doesn't matter and the point is
is going to win by a temple tough way
losing by one temple but you know this
is this is how mind games work sometimes
so this was good news for Wesley so
winning his first game of the day it's
very tough to lose two games in a row so
it's very important to bounce back the
gap goes back to three points but now
this is a better situation for Fabiano
karana because the clutch games are
awarded three points each so he just
needs one win to even out the score but
before we go into clutch changes one
more game left so seemingly harmless
position you know we have this
caro-kann end game that we see a lot
black plays h5 looks like a normal move
fixing the pawn structure on the Kings
side except rugby three and now upon is
falling there is no b6 this guy's
hanging there's no tnt running into a
fork and it was a good crucial punt and
what the problem is once the b7 pawn
Hanks okay like monstapiece of Infante
falls then the c6 pawn is going to
become a problem so night that's not
what happened so root PT was played so
Bishop d6 night c4 so now we're going to
see some bad things happen to this
Bishop and he resigns because the bishop
is just getting trapped next night will
come to d3 the rook has to go to do you
want and we can just come and the King
can run and trap it and at the same time
we're also attacking the pawn on c6 so
we can just simply win the pawn and then
come back and do that the problem is the
bishop just cannot escape like we'll
have to give up some some more material
with something like you should g5 but
this is just this it's just too many
puns
and there's no reason to keep playing
this so now finally it's time for clutch
games so going into clutch games the
score for the day is three to one in
favor of Fabiano Fabiana has found that
three games in the day and has lost one
so psychologically that's a very
difficult thing to deal with when you
enter the day with a four point lead and
then you lose three games and you know
like you're just in a different place
mentally because maybe what's the
thought it was going to be an easy day
although I highly doubt because it's a
professional player okay so let's take a
look or crucial at our crucial game so
the winning this game is worth three
points so we're on move 62 so Fabiano
Khurana very clearly doing really well
he's up the exchange it has a pawn on h2
not the kind of position that was Caesar
wanted to find himself in with the white
pieces but talk about a clutch play
right getting this kind of position in a
must-win situation so e4 we exchanged so
looks like some kind of compensation but
Fabiano's handles this position
excellently so it comes to the open file
Bishop g4 very logical move at some
point the bishop might go to f3 I'm
pinning this rope down basically and
rook f4 it's a route gage three would
have been a better move so we get four
is plate me six and now Bishop f5 so
Bishop by five is not the best move in
the position it's better to cover up the
for threatening to go root t2 so there's
a funny line it's a for example if white
checks gets the rock out place Knight
see for stopping the rope now black has
this really funny movie for because the
rook is untouchable because of the pawn
and we're threatening rookie to so
things are not looking good for white
instead Bishop f5 was played Bishop went
rogue went to see one
so Bishop h3 check takes the pawn
it's a regifter was a try but this is
already times rumble they have seconds
left so let's just take a look at what
happened so bishop goes back d7 goes
back and now the final mistake by Wesley
sir which costs in the game because here
comes Rock d7 Rob takes normally this
kind of tactic wouldn't work because the
rookie on this salmon is under attack
now rocked it to check and after the
King runs away now this is just a matter
of technique because we're going to see
that this pawns just not going to live
for very long and there goes the knight
understandable mistake to make but the
position was already lost and just a
matter of technique and this would win
with this a very clutch victory now
Fabiano Caruana is a point ahead of his
opponent and all he needs is a draw with
the white pieces in the front and the
final game so by now you know what
happened in that game oh actually maybe
you don't know what happened in thinking
maybe he won that game but let's take a
look and actually see what happened in
that game so I have to disappoint you
this game was not very interesting and
the way it ended was a little bit
strange to me so what happened is in
this position
Fabiana goes rooks e1 and he starts
repeating and for some reason Wesley
decides to repeat and make a draw which
allows his opponent to advance so I'm
not sure why he decided to do this
because a draw or a loss are the same
there is no difference in money for him
there is no you know placing higher on
the standings either way he gets knocked
out so I'm not sure why he didn't try
for more maybe he was already feeling
jaded but I don't have an explanation
only he knows why he decided to go for a
drum but you know pretty comfortable
draw for white for Fabian Khurana who
advances to the finals Wesley so was
very gracious in his postgame interview
he did congratulate his opponent and
wished him the best and he also said
that Fabriano today and Fabiana
yesterday were just like two completely
different players and he if Wesley
himself ran out of steam and Fabiana
just came to fight and and fight he did
so congratulations once again to Fabiano
Khurana and let's move on to our next
match so the next match mm-hmm so the
other match was between Levon Aronian
and Magnus Carlsen so if you watched my
video yesterday you know that lemon or
onion really suffered in the hands of
Magnus Carlsen here was also behind four
points just like Fabiana was but there
was no comeback by the Armenian
superstar and I said that he suffered in
the hands of Magnus Carlsen and
unfortunately today was not much better
so we have this position so let's count
pounds 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 so down
to pawns but black does have the two
bishops and the pushing response is not
so easy so what we're going to see next
is actually very surprising
so 92 and here comes route k4 so really
an astonishing way of playing this
position not a move I would have thought
about but the point is to destroy this
pawn structure so now rotate once you
destroy a pawn structure you want to
capture those pawns
so if you compare the positions look at
how nice this I get how nice this is
compared to what we have to move later
and how every pawn is hanging and now
look at this King go if it goes back
hey five so LaVon decides to give up the
exchange for activity so this position
still objectively should be better for
white but black starts but 11 starts
losing the right of the game so this
rock looks a little funny here so
exchanging everything and going for this
work end game so once again a real game
game so you know what's coming
nothing good happens in rock n game this
is this should be the conclusion of this
tournament so this is was a really
heartbreaking that 11 actually ended up
losing this but if you look at it he is
on the worst side of the draw because
he's up a pawn but blacks King is very
active this pawn may not survive and
this one is going to fall he cannot hang
on to every pawn and he has to actually
defend this
so he goes rogue g6 magma starts to push
and the crucial mistakes a mistake of
taking this pawn instead he should play
rook e6 and ask like what is it going to
do with this pawns because if you take
we're exchanging it's going to be much
easier to draw this you have to go here
then rookie six I can try to take this
pawn my king will come and stop this guy
your King is cut off or if you decide to
go on e4 and I have rookie five
conveniently attacking this pawn which
blocks the question how you're going to
both defend the pawn stop my past fun
and attack this guy so it's very hard to
do so many things at the same time of
course but instead Rock age six was
played and once again as we sign the
other game these bonds are just so much
faster and here he just resigns because
he cannot go for this Queen where Queen
position because he's getting made it
it's a really heartbreaking loss and
actually was kind of funny because in
the postgame interview Magnus said you
know when you win a game like this you
kind of think you think like nothing can
go wrong for you and it's true right
because you suffering drink during the
game but you still manage to win it
playing against such a strong player and
Magnus is of course a very confident
players so this must have been an extra
boost and he did say he came to the day
feeling very confident some imagined you
come to the day feeling very confident
you get a bad positioning you still win
then you know your confidence is through
the roof rightfully so so let's take a
look at the next game so Magnus is
playing with the white pieces and he
said this was his favorite game of the
round and this was actually an
incredible game there's a really
beautiful moment that wasn't played but
I will show you what could have been so
Rudy - that one goes rook c8 okay 211
goes Knight c8 unfortunate move because
rook e8 and now you're really tight down
can really move anyone so he runs away
with the king queen h5 so we know what
the plan is
Bishop goes to have 586 and this was a
really incredible moment in the game
Magnus played Bishop HD which is of
course a great move but there was this
chance to go for this and there's this
incredible move in g6
and just leaving the Queen under attack
so the idea is you're threatening mates
the black has to react it so black has
to take and now you take here and now we
see that it's difficult to defend
everyone so for example if you take so
you cannot block because I'll try it and
then window tonight at the end so you
have to go g5 stop the mate
and this king is a little bit of travel
here so what I think mate so what to do
is to play g6 and the problem is now
we're going to attack the Queen
ask her where she's going so the Queen
doesn't have any many options because if
she leaves
there's mate so she's forced to go back
and now that things are happening again
so I cannot go up I'll just take a pawn
and we win a queen so if really
incredible line so Magnus is like you
could see this look on his face like he
was looking at something is there but he
didn't go for this but let's go back to
this position after Bishop e6 so we took
a look at Queen e6 so this is also a
possibility but this position should
just be lost and just looks very bad
with the two minor pieces for the rook
so let's go back to the game so in the
game Bishop h3 was played c6
takes on d6 wins the Queen and things go
horribly wrong for him look f2 and we
see this the weakness of the King and
everything is hanging this is hanging
this is hanging Queenie made his hanging
so you cannot look for any kind of
activity so I'm at so Magnus was another
game so he's now plus 6 and having this
kind of elitist of course mathematically
was still past impossible for LaVon to
come back he needed to make it dry in
the next two games which he did the next
two games are not very interesting I
will just very quickly take you through
them if you look at this final position
that we have on the board you can
already tell that not a lot of things
happen in this game I don't want to
spend any time talking about them I will
just show you like quickly f5 just going
for this kind of draw it's nothing one
word for us to look at this and this
game similar things happened once again
in this position
Magnus cause if we go back one more move
Magnus goes have five clarifying the
position we enter another opposite color
Bishop position with no life in it and
the game ends in a John so Magnus is at
plastics
so if Levin wins the next two games with
each game being worth three points he
will win the match but when is the last
time you know someone won on-demand two
times maybe you might be thinking to
2019 single Cup playoffs but after
losing the first game in that situation
magnets needed to win and here he just
needs a half a point out of two so a
little bit of a different situation so
in this position Magnus plays rook ft8
and this is actually a pretty
instructive game giving up to be two
rooks for a queen but let's see how
things go wrong for eleven months again
so let's just take a look at what
happens so a lot of exchanges happen I
just want to take you to a key position
so all this exchanges happen and now he
just starts to outplay his opponent g5
creating an outpost for his knight
Knight come out and again we see this
combination of a queen and a knight and
I already mentioned this that this
combination of a queen and a knight when
they attack together it's lethal and but
the action is on one side of the board
so there isn't that much material left
on the board so why does manage to
defend this so rooty files and when the
action is only one side of the board the
knight is actually superior to the
bishop so we're going to see how this
Bishop becomes kind of useless and if I
have a very annoying hoof and so he
decides to take take and go for a
fortress the point is if you try to be
clever go after my phone I have a five
and you cannot take well you can't but
you know get to this position and here I
don't think you're gonna be able to hold
the fortress although it's possible but
again who's playing for a week I mean a
must-win situation game instead he goes
he takes this and he builds a fortress
and to Magnus notoriously has said it
doesn't believe in fortresses but
believes enough takes takes crucial move
at four takes and we see how everyone is
exchanged
so magnus carlsen clinches the victory
in this match and qualifies to the
finals so the last game was also a drum
I will destroy the final position we
don't have to go through the game
neither player I really wanted to do
anything
- Carlson was impressing for a win and
that won our union wasn't going to so we
end up in this Kingdom game with pretty
symmetrical position so clearly not a
lot of action happened here so tomorrow
we're going to have a very exciting
match between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Khurana I know we've seen these two
players play a lot but they do produce
some amazing games a lot of great fights
so this is not a event you want to miss
it's going to be a lot of fun and with
the clutch games with the clutch games
offering more points you know anything
can happen if one of the players who's
trailing as we saw Fabiana was today can
win one of those games and even out the
match so make sure you are tuning in
tomorrow the games start at the same
time 1:00 p.m. central 2 p.m. Eastern
see you guys then